la columna vertebral se compone de
huesos llamados vértebras apilados uno
encima del otro
las vértebras protegen unas de fibras
nerviosas llamado médula espinal este se
extiende a través de una abertura en el
centro de cada vértebra
las principales secciones de la columna
vertebral son las regiones cervical
torácica y lumbar
si se la mira desde el costado la
columna vertebral normalmente tiene tres
curvas una se en la columna cervical una
se invertida en la columna torácica y
otra se en la columna lumbar
vista desde atrás la columna debe verse
completamente recta arriba y abajo la
escoliosis es una afección donde la
columna vertebral tiene una curvatura
anormal de lado a lado la mayoría de los
casos de escoliosis no tiene una causa
conocida en algunos casos la escoliosis
puede estar presente en el nacimiento en
otros casos puede ocurrir con el tiempo
la causa más común en los adultos es la
degeneración asimétrica de los discos
que hace que la columna vertebral se
incline hacia un lado o el otro otras
causas pueden incluir parálisis cerebral
parálisis distrofia muscular
osteoporosis o fracturas vertebrales
durante la infancia generalmente la
curva de la columna empeora durante los
periodos de rápido crecimiento si la
curva se agrava puede causar problemas
con la postura para caminar y dolor de
espalda
también puede hacer que a los órganos
internos les falte espacio y causar
problemas de corazón respiración y
digestión
la escoliosis a menudo se trata con un
aparato ortopédico para que la curva no
siga empeorando
los médicos deben medir la curva de la
columna vertebral a lo largo del tiempo
para ver si la ortesis funciona para un
adolescente puede ser necesaria una
intervención quirúrgica si la ortesis no
funciona o si no hay opción de colocar
un aparato ortopédico para un adulto con
escoliosis puede ser necesaria una
intervención quirúrgica si experimenta
adormecimiento o debilidad en las
piernas o bien si tiene dolor de espalda
que empeora progresivamente y que no
mejora con tratamientos no quirúrgicos
el procedimiento quirúrgico más común
para reparar la escoliosis se llama
fusión espinal posterior con
instrumentación e injerto óseo
para empezar el cirujano hace una
abertura sobre el área de la curva de la
columna vertebral las superficies de las
vértebras se raspan para hacerlas
rugosas y promover que los huesos curen
juntos
el cirujano colocará tornillos ganchos o
alambres en las vértebras
se colocan varillas a lo largo de las
vértebras y se unen a tornillos ganchos
o cables con el fin de enderezar la
columna vertebral
el cirujano puede extraer pequeños
trozos de hueso de la pelvis para
usarlos como injertos óseos
en otras ocasiones el cirujano puede
optar por utilizar hueso de donante de
un banco de huesos para injertos el
cirujano coloca los injertos de hueso a
lo largo de la columna vertebral para
permitir que las vértebras crezcan
juntas y mantengan la columna vertebral
estable al final del procedimiento la
incisión se cierra con una sutura